the most important thing that Obama has
meant to me personally is this ring
around my finger I am married to men who
I have lived with for 30 years
big thing he gave was just hope we jump
some barriers when Barack Obama got into
the tear President Barack Obama to me is
the perfect introduction to hard work as
a man we have both like a sheepdog with
a very curly hair so I feel very close
to him it was really nice to have a
president who understood bravery I'm so
excited for my children that the only
president they've really ever known has
been Obama they've never known a world
without a black president and I think
that is great you know those kids out
there who are growing up who think that
it's not possible to be in a position of
authority or power or leadership is
being president and it's working down in
that myth I really look up to him and
fact that he was a fan awesome eloquent
elegant dignified will probably go down
as one of the greatest presidents we've
ever had it's really nice to have a
president that is really kind and very
very nice Obama's progress Obama is
understanding a symbol of hope you know
our faith someone who had a heart as big
as his brain I was a huge Tupac fan and
he said in a song they'll never be a
black president when I heard that lyric
I was like yeah of course yeah what yeah
I get it
I know that's not the case and I know
that I've seen a miracle President Obama
is
magnificent a mixture of great gravitas
and lightness simultaneously something
that I think will be sorely missed I
don't want him to go it'll be cool to
tell like you know my grandkids about it
like kind of like yeah like first black
president like I was there everybody
felt like we have a community
accomplished something I'm really
pleased and blessed and proud of this
president and I'll be sad to see him go
so thank you for your service sir
love you
[Music]